foreign
Earth's neighbor
the destination of NASA's most ambitious
mission to date
but this Expedition will be harder than
we ever thought possible
hurts to think of how hard it is
farthest a human being has ever been
from the earth we gotta take every
precaution
as NASA astronauts arrive at Mars they
will face a huge obstacle
landing on the planet is a daunting task
in the past
Mars hasn't always rolled out the
welcome mat
Mars is kind of like a graveyard for
spacecraft it's actually really hard to
send something from Earth and land it on
Mars this is how the European Space
Agency hoped its 250 million dollar
skiaparelli Lander would touch down in
2016.
but the Landers systems got it wrong
[Music]
parachute detached early sending the
craft into free fall for 33 seconds
caparelli smashed into the surface at
335 miles per hour
leaving a deep black Scar in The Martian
landscape
particularly difficult planet to land on
even Humanity's most brilliant Engineers
we've got about a 50 success rate when
it comes to landing on Mars
the red planet is littered with dead
spacecraft that didn't nail The Landing
for NASA's first crude descent to Mars
the space agency must learn from these
mistakes
but as the crew hurtles towards the
surface they're battling the same
problem as all the Landers that failed
before
the Martian atmosphere is 100 times
thinner than Earth's so it can't provide
the drag needed to slow a spacecraft
town
so it's not like the Earth where you can
have these big giant parachutes that
gently Glide you down to the surface
you can use some of the air but
it's hard
[Music]
the red planet's then atmosphere is a
problem that has been billions of years
in the making Mars doesn't have a large
atmosphere because it's constantly being
peeled away due to the lack of
protection of a magnetic field
the solar wind can strip away an
atmosphere
on earth a liquid metal core creates a
magnetic field which Shields the planet
and helps maintain the atmosphere
but Mars is different
4.5 billion years ago Mars and Earth
formed from dust and gas in space
Mars formed where building materials
were scarce
growth was stunning
so Mars is much smaller than the earth
it's a factor of 10 smaller than the
earth and that factor of 10 in mass is
important all of that extra mass allows
the inside of the earth to stay warm and
to have a core that's rotating
which generates a magnetic field
four billion years ago the churning
heart of Mars started to cool and
solidify
with no hot core there's no magnetic
field being generated
all of the high velocity charged
particles coming from the Sun pick away
at the atmosphere and slowly tear it
away
we know it's losing atmosphere every
second due to the solar wind so you know
bye bye atmosphere
if NASA's astronauts arrive on Mars as
planned in 2035 the settlers will find
one of the red planet's biggest
challenges
is it dust
that's sticky uh basically light from
the sun can give this stuff a static
charge and then it clings to stuff so
it's not just a matter of like you know
standing on a doormat outside your your
space habitat and shaking yourself off
it's gonna get in your spacesuit it's
going to coat your visor it's going to
cover your solar panels
if you get it in your lungs it's not a
good thing we have to figure out how to
clear this stuff out
300 feet and it's 11.
through the 60s and 70s
Apollo Astronauts walked on the moon
when they returned to their Landing
module they brought Moon dust back with
them
the lunar dust clogged seals caused
equipment to overheat resulted in false
instrument readings and even made
astronauts sick
you don't want to be breathing in fine
Dusty material
by itself you can get things like
silicosis it's a it's a you know almost
basically a lung cancer that you can get
just from breathing the dust itself you
don't want to do that
the red planet is covered in sticky dust
a new research suggests it all came from
one place
the Medusa Fosse formation
when the 600 mile long volcanic deposit
formed three billion years ago it was
around half the size of the United
States but the Martian winds have eroded
this structure and spread the dust
across the entire planet
when the wind whips up this dust it can
have disastrous consequences
real problem is just that all these fine
particles get lofted into the atmosphere
and it takes a really long time for them
to settle back out and what the dust
does is it just gets up in the sky and
it sits there and sits there and sits
there
as more material gets lifted into the
atmosphere it forms huge dust storms
the storms are so huge they block out
the sunlight and cool the Martian
surface
creating a temperature difference
between the ground and atmosphere that
causes winds to increase and the storms
to grow
and NASA's opportunity Rover knows
firsthand the dangers of being trapped
in one
opportunity was a NASA rover sent to
Mars to hunt for signs of past water on
the surface and potentially signs of
past life
this is a Rover that we really worked
with so long knew so well and who had
come up with so many amazing new results
from Mars
June 2018
opportunity was 15 years into its
mission
when giant clouds of dust appeared on
the horizon
NASA could only watch as the storm grew
and grew
once this dust storm coated the entire
planet it blocked the sun and the sun
was the source of opportunity's power
opportunity Works using solar panels and
so it gradually got less and less and
less electricity
for opportunity there was no Escape
lost in the darkness opportunities power
reserves slowly ran dry
the Rover fell silent
[Music]